well last night in canton big ben would
not have been playing the cowboys
starters wouldn't have been playing mike
tomlin would have been coaching his
fourth stringers against
mike mccarthy the new cowboys coach if
there had been a hall of fame game
that's the first tangible thing that we
have seen fall victim
to the pandemic as it relates to nfl
games no hall of fame game
uh but the hall of fame ceremony also
not happening this weekend
reminded us of combined with a couple of
other things i saw on twitter this week
there was a question whether patrick
mahomes would get in the hall of fame if
he retired right
now which i think is just kind of kooky
he's played 31 regular season games
but we we kicked around this idea if the
world were to end today and we
understand that if the world ended today
the hall of fame would be gone with it
but in the event that football just
stopped that it was over that was done
today but the hall of fame still existed
which current players would make it
into canton now we're leaving
out the no-brainers drew brees tom brady
adrian peterson larry fitzgerald
the guys who have been around for more
than a decade that already have the
credentials that if they walked away
right now or
if the world ended right now they would
get in we're going to focus this one
shireen on guys with 10 years or less
and you're a hall of fame
voters so what you say here has a hell
of a lot more credibility than what i
say
so let's start with the guys that we
think are the no-brainer no
doubter hall of famers with 10 or fewer
years of experience in the nfl
if football ended for good today
well i actually did nine years or or
less so this being nine's fine
nine's fine nine or less yeah okay
you know when i actually came up with
with the more guys than i
and then i thought i would come up with
and and i'm going to start though with
with aaron donald i don't you know we
didn't mention him in in the guy that
has the potential to break the sack
record and here's a guy who had 20 and a
half sacks and led the league two years
ago i mean he is the best to me he's the
best player in the nfl
now you're gonna say well it's patrick
mahomes he's a quarterback i realize
that i realize patrick mahomes is
is a quarterback and has more perhaps
impact on the game but i think aaron
donald for what he does for as long as
he's done it
which is only six years has been
phenomenal one of the best players in
nfl history
he he's won a couple of uh defensive
player of the year awards he already has
72 sacks in his career he's been to the
pro bowl every year five all pros i mean
i don't know what else you want
from a player aaron donald's done more
in six years than a lot of players do in
10
15 20 years in the league i just think
he's been phenomenal so i'd start right
there and
and then there's a ton more of pass
rushers who i think are right there with
him with clil mack and j.j watt and
and and von miller i think to me all are
first ballot hall of famers with what
they've done in their careers so far
i agree with you on jj watt without
question three-time defensive player of
the year
that puts him in regardless of any other
accolades
von miller is an interesting one i mean
he's got a ton of sacks i think he gets
in
if he if he goes it's almost that
terrell davis gail sayers career
right where you've got the super bowl
trophy you've got the super bowl mvp if
you're von miller did you play
long enough is nine years enough and i
think for jj watt
and for von miller it is and i agree
with you for aaron donald six years
is more than enough given the skill that
he's displayed and what he's achieved as
an
interior defensive lineman getting 20
and a half sacks
as a guy rushing from the inside is
almost unheard of so uh what i would
agree what
and uh uh what and
who's the other guy von miller yes sorry
i forgot what von miller
donald yeah and but what about khalil
mack you mentioned him he's another one
that arrived in 2015
2014 rather has he done enough
in his limited time to get in the way
that aaron donald would get in
you know i he was a kind of almost an
afterthought that i moved off the
up for discussion list on to this list
simply because he's had
uh five pro bowls he's had three uh
all pro things and he was all decade and
we'll
you know we can get into an all-decade
debate it used to be automatic that
that when you made the all-decade team
that you automatically got into the
hall of fame but there was a first team
in a second team until this year and
this year we've all gone to clumping
them together so there's multiple
players at every position
so i'm not sure that's going to happen
there's a bunch of guys on that list
that i would not say
are hall of famers who made the all
decade team for the 2010s
but i do think that that khalil mack
with his all decade with his
he was defensive player of the year one
year i just i think he's done enough
that you would say
all right i'm gonna get in now maybe
he's not that first ballot guy but i do
think he's done enough to get into the
hall of fame
we haven't mentioned quarterbacks
quarterbacks with nine or fewer seasons
russell wilson would be at the top of
the list of guys who get in he was
drafted in third round in 2012.
two super bowl appearances you know he's
never had an mvp
vote and we mention that from time to
time and i i don't think it's as
shocking as it would
appear because it's one vote per voter
it's 50 voters per year there isn't
first place second place third place i
think judge the
circumstances you know he's had his best
seasons when there is a clear-cut
no-brainer who gets all or almost all of
the votes
but he's clearly a first ballot hall of
famer shireen if he never takes another
snap in the nfl either by choice
or because the world has ended
absolutely i had him on my list uh you
know he's played eight years six pro
bowls and
and and has the super bowl and led his
team to a couple super bowls and and
been one of the outstanding quarterbacks
uh while he's in his time in the league
and
you know when you talk about not getting
a vote for mvp
and drew brees has never been he's going
to make the hall of fame first bout
he's never been first team all pro
he's never won an mvp award now he's
gotten mvp votes and he finished second
at least one time i know to ladainian
thomason
but but he's going to enter the hall of
fame without those credentials too and
it just so happens that other players
have had better years in the years that
they've had their best seasons but
russell wilson to me no doubt is is a
first ballot
what about other quarterbacks shireen
that have
nine or few we lost shireen shireen is
gone maybe the world is in the process
of ending
it started in dallas and it's working
its way up here
that's not funny at all uh we'll get
shireen back i'm trying to think of
other quarterbacks
that have that nine or fewer years of
experience you know
we're going to talk about patrick holmes
i uh with with
two with two seasons of starting
uh experience i just don't think that's
enough cam newton is a guy who was an
nfl mvp has he done enough to get in i
think you can make a better case for cam
newton just because
he's played a heck of a lot longer
shireen is back shireen i was concerned
the world was ending and the epicenter
was dallas
i'm glad that you're back we've moved on
to other quarterbacks cam newton is the
next one i want to talk about because
i don't think he's the same no-brainer
that russell wilson is although he's won
an mvp award
and russell wilson hasn't even gotten a
vote
well i hate cam newton as my long shot
to make it i think he needs to play more
years i think he needs to do more in the
league than
than what he's done so far i mean
everybody makes the pro bowl every year
right
mike even even at the quarterback
position i mean look at andy dalton and
some of the things he's done because so
many guys pull
out because it doesn't include the super
bowl teams he's made three pro bowls in
his career so i don't think he's done
enough at this point i think he needs to
have have some success in new england
and has some success over multiple years
before we talk about cam newton as a
hall of famer
so what other quarterbacks that's the
thing the dominant quarterbacks in the
nfl
right are either really old and
no-brainers
or so young that you can't make uh you
can't make a
lamar jackson one season of starting
he's not getting to the hall of fame
patrick mahomes
i'm sorry anyone who thinks patrick
mahomes is getting the hall of fame if
he stops playing today
two seasons is not getting you into the
hall of fame he's on track to be one of
the best ever
but you can't just walk off or have the
world end after two seasons and expect
to get in
is there any other quarterback that
stands out to you
that you know andrew luck i mean he if
he'd played last year
but even then would he have done enough
he hasn't done enough in his career
yeah so if we lost shireen again
shireen's gonna get maybe
i'm not gonna joke about the world
ending anymore until i have proof that
it's not we'll get shireen back
um and we'll see how during the break
she reacts to technical difficulties
we know how our friend chris sims reacts
to technical difficulties i have a
feeling
shireen probably slightly more
controlled
and calm than christopher david sims who
uh
shireen is back shireen hopefully there
was no profanity from you during the
technical
difficulty but um you know there really
isn't
back to the quarterbacks uh andrew luck
like i said i mean i don't know that
he'd be a candidate he's already retired
uh you know we've got matt ryan and
we've got philip rivers or on the other
side of ten years
let's go ahead and expand the window
just for them because they're really not
no-brainers
right now right um if they if they're
done right now
do either or both get in well i think
i would put matt ryan in that long shot
category and i would put philip rivers
in that up
up for debate category and i know he's
going to finish
you know with all kinds of you know top
tens
in in all the legitimate categories that
that we judge but you know not getting
to a super bowl not getting to that many
playoffs
you know i just not making an all decade
team you know there's just some things
there i think that are missing from
philip rivers career that he has a
chance to make right right now to be a
first ballot hall of famer and
having said all that dan phelps got into
the hall of fame from the charters and
and uh philip rivers is going to end up
having a better career than what dan
fouts did and so i i think he's probably
going to go in
i just don't think he's a no-brainer i
think there's going to be a lot of
discussion about him as there will be
for eli manning frankly
and both of those guys are going to be
really difficult difficult
decisions to make i think he does get in
at some point but i don't think it's
going to be as easy as probably he would
like
or his team would like unless he can go
on and lead the colts
to some big things this year or next
year or plays a few more years
rivers in eye both in that class of 2004
ben roethlisberger name we haven't
mentioned in my mind he's a no-brainer i
mean we need to mention i agree i think
he's in no matter what right
okay agreed i didn't want to leave him
out yeah i don't want to leave him out
one way or the other but i think he's in
it's a given he should have been
mentioned along with brees and
brady and larry fitzgerald all right
let's speaking of larry fitzgerald let's
slide to receivers now
julio jones would be one the first one
that comes to mind for me and
especially because he started in 2011
he's got the nine years he gets in under
the
under the the 10-year limit uh has he
done enough to get in he's 25th all-time
in receiving yards
he doesn't have a whole lot of
touchdowns especially in the red zone
does he get in does he have to wait uh
or does he get in at all
sharing no i think he gets in i had him
on my list of if the world who ended
today he would go in you know the 12
000 yards and he's got seven pro bowls
he was on the all decade team to me
which is big that means he was one of
the best receivers
of the past decade something that aj
green which i'm sure we're going to talk
about him in a second
didn't get on which i think is big for
him when you start talking about hall of
fame we are going to look at that all
the receivers that got on there and he
wasn't one of them
that got on there so i think cooley
julio jones is a lock to get in you look
what he did in the super bowl too if you
want some signature moments
uh he has those in the super bowl and i
think it was sort of like
uh terrell owens the year that
philadelphia went to the super bowl if
the eagles had won that i i
think that he would have been mvp and i
think he would add a legitimate case in
the super bowl
uh if they had won that that julio jones
was the mvp of the super bowl as many
big plays as he made in that game so i
think he has
everything he checks off every box that
you want a hall of fame player to check
off
he made that catch when the falcons were
up 28-20 with about five minutes left in
the game or thereabouts
that to me i thought was the dagger it
was a sideline catch remember that
kind of on the sideline great catch and
and i think you're right if they win
that game he's got a good
as good a chance of anyone on that
roster i think would have been down to
him and matt ryan to be the mvp and
julio jones very well may have been the
mvp
i think he's definitely well i don't
know that i want to say definitely
because it's so competitive at receiver
there's so many guys who have racked up
stats to be 25th all-time
receiving yards i don't know that it's
definite i think he's in after a weight
like we've seen with so many other great
receivers aj green's number 67 on the
all-time yardage list with 8 900 yards
and he just gets overlooked and
forgotten i think part of that is
playing in cincinnati
uh i think he's gonna have a hard time
getting in if he's done
as of right now oh absolutely no
question about it i think he's got to do
more in his career and
not playing last year probably hurt him
a little bit too but
yeah he's got to do more i think he's up
for debate
eight years he's got seven pro bowls and
and the no all decade thing again to me
was big
you know he wasn't one of the four best
receivers of the last decade which i
think says a lot
uh when you start judging these things
and and you know it's hard to judge
stats anymore passing stats especially
for receivers because they throw the
ball so much more than they did
even 10 or 15 years ago and so uh he's
got to do more he he needs to
probably have some playoff success have
us i can't even think of a signature
catch we always talk about signature
catches when we get in the room
you talk about what was his signature
play i don't have an aj green signature
play
simply because they haven't done
anything in the playoffs since he's been
in cincinnati
a guy who technically has been around
for 10 years
but only played one game last year
antonio brown a guy who
who very well as far as his nfl
career is concerned may be done that he
may be in the barn
he's got 11 263 receiving yards he was
on a super bowl
team as a rookie never won a
championship was
for several years post calvin johnson
the best receiver in the nfl
what are his chances of getting in and
how much does the turmoil that he
created over the past 18 months affect
him
to me it's teo all over again right i
mean
you're not supposed to talk about what
doesn't happen between the lines and i
think that's exactly what we're going to
be discussing
how divisive was he on the teams he
played on all as
you know you're not supposed to consider
off-field stuff but i think you do
in his case at least in the back of your
mind with uh
you know with what went on with him not
being able to play
last year i mean that was significant
and that did
factor in because of his off the field
stuff he didn't get to play
a full almost a full season he played
one game so with the patriots so he
missed 15 games last year so
uh you do think about those things but
you know he has
all the yards that you want he has you
know for all pros he has
seven pro bowls nine paroles whatever he
has i mean he's
he's done it he's put up the yards he's
made some signature catches he's done a
lot of good things that you want him to
do but there's just a bigger discussion
there
with what he's meant to his team and
what he's done
uh on the field in a leadership role in
helping his team get to a super bowl and
win a super bowl and
and so i i think he's a huge discussion
he did make the all-decade team which i
think weighs in his favor
but i to me it's a lot like the t.o
discussion
well and you know we have to factor in
the human dynamics of what goes on in
the room you are
in that room every year who's going to
stand up and make the case
for antonio brown to get in is ed
bouchette still the steelers
representative he is is he is it still
him yeah i think he is there there's
been some
there's been some there's been some
venom between antonio brown and ed
bouchette
right you need somebody who's going to
make a passionate case for you to get in
and i don't know that ed bouchette is
going to be all that motivated to do so
and i can't say i blame him recalling
some of the
things that antonio brown wrongly
accused ed buchet
of before he you know talked and tweeted
his way out of pittsburgh so
if you don't have an advocate in the
room you're not getting in
and i think that's a factor for antonio
brown that could make it hard for him to
get in as well at a minimum he's gonna
have to wait several years
even then he may not get in he may have
to come back and play several more years
at a high level
to try to cement his case and maybe do
it with a team that that would have a
representative
at the hall of fame meeting that would
stand up and and stand on the table to
get antonio brown in
i got to ask you about some cowboys
specifically jason whitton
no longer a cowboy but and and and he's
out of the window but
you know tight ends are on a ton of
tight ends in the hall of fame
he's up there statistically i i i assume
he gets in
shireen and i assume that you're not the
most objective voice to ask about that
since you'd be presenting him
yeah right well i probably will present
jason witton and i do think he deserves
to get in yeah we
i don't think we've treated tight ends
you know
favorably uh over the years but it is
getting more with tony gonzalez and and
i would expect antonio gates to go in
eventually and i think travis kelsey is
is one guy that we can mention here is
up for debate with what
he's done so far in his career with
seven years he's certainly on track to
go into the hall of fame but
uh when you look at jason wooden i think
he's done a lot of great things i think
again it goes back he does have a
signature play
we all remember the play against
philadelphia when his helmet came off
and he continued to run and got
downfield and i think that kind of
defined
what jason whitton is and was all about
and and he's come back from retirement
did okay last season the touchdown
numbers are concerning there's no
question about
that and he'll be better off if he can
go to
los alamos at oakland but if he can go
to las vegas and have a good season this
year and
and maybe get a few more touchdowns i
think that will help his case even more
i'm not sure he's the first ballot hall
of famer i hope he is i'm not
positive he is a first ballot hall of
famer but i do think he goes in
it took michael irvin three years and it
might take jason witten three years as
well
there are plenty of other positions we
get didn't get to what i'm going to do
is i'm going to put a cork in this
bottle hope the world doesn't end today
and then some point next week we'll
we'll address
linebackers corners safeties offensive
line and maybe even specialists as well
when we return though speaking of the
cowboys speaking of past catchers
who is the number two receiver this year
for dallas there are multiple candidates
to be the number two receiver we're
gonna have some fun with that next here
on pf2
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports